the news has been pretty awful lately  right the news has been a drag you get  up in the morning you look at the news  it's a drag between extremist groups  like Isis in the Middle East and this  new Ebola scare right here in America  now it almost feels like the Grim Reaper  himself is messing with us so I decided  if the Grim Reaper is gonna mess with us  let's see if we can't mess with the Grim  Reaper right yeah cuz it we did here's  what we did we sent a crew out to prank  the Grim Reaper and film it here's what  we did first right before breakfast we  emptied out his milk check this out then  we snuck into his house and we shrunk  his brand-new jeans check that out next  we slipped a red sock into his white  laundry man that's annoying  then we hacked into his bank account and  change this ATM PIN number that's  embarrassing finally tonight we really  got him check it out you know hoodie  [Applause]  you  [Applause]  you